every once in a while you hear a lot of
people say well this is the most
interesting man in the world and and
you'll watch those SEC years you know if
the dis man so interesting and that
guy's so interesting but we're actually
hanging out with the real life most
interesting man in the world
Gianluca lucky brother thank you so much
nice place beautiful you have your mom
and you want in the whole view of this
Miami headed here so think and I know
you want your boat today
it's great hanging out with you thank
you so so for those who don't know you
you know who is Gianluca Bucky because
in America is your Instagram 11.5
million use you're on Jay Baldwin's
video which you're all dance and your
dance moves you got tell us a lot about
yourself and how you got to where you
are today first of all you made me laugh
a little bit because in 2000 like 2011
when I was totally unknown I used to
hang out with with a famous actress and
the international newspapers used to
call me like the Dos Equis guy you know
then and from there maybe originated the
thing of the most interesting real life
man in the world I think it fits with
you I'm very grateful to life because he
gave me the chance to have two lives you
know until 45 years old I was like an
active entrepreneur even today I'm an
entrepreneur because you know once you
manage the risk of being a shareholder
in industrial companies even if they are
managed by other person sure you still
learn entrepreneur because we did that
being or not entrepreneur is determined
by the fact that you are running the
risk of the company are actually
involved but then from 45 I started to
like be not so much curious about
financial matters or and so I decided to
watch I was watching like how the
conventions of dialogue of the way of
dialogue between young people was
reaching
and because I was like going to dinner
with younger people and I was watching
that any of the of the person at the
dinner was not talking with the person
beside or in front but just talking with
the smartphone and so I said to myself
I'm not old enough not to be interested
in our way of communication of
communication are changing you know and
so I started to I started to say that if
I would have like shown my life as it
was because like my life was like this
even when I was like doing serious stuff
entrepreneurial stuff so you've always
been partying always had a guy I was
always laughing smiling and and then
joking and taking myself not too serious
even when I was doing serious stuff and
I said I can become a global Entertainer
of the new platform and this is what I
became and I was totally aware that for
the conventional world in which I was
living it Italy for example as soon as I
would have done something public like a
dance step for example or I would have
like had many problems with the
conventional world you know of course of
course because you know when when you
leave it'll be a very conservative world
you know I I heard so many times I it
totally gone is his brain is gone his
watch is dancing on Instagram watches
but they didn't understand is dead is
not because you do something Alerus or
comic or or or dancing or that you
cannot do silly stuff in because when
and what I always used to say is that
people that don't laugh are not serious
people you know Wow people that don't
laugh on that is like for people that
don't laugh are not serious people I
like that yes because to be serious you
need to laugh you know those those
people that appear always series are
fake series you know because they
they're always acting you know this is
that this is the interesting this is
what I think is what I think you know so
but the thing is that in Italy have been
criticized a lot a lot now everybody's
saying oh what she's a genius what he
saw the direction he said but it is but
first any time I did something pretty
strange even under that day entrepreneur
point of view I've been I was judged
like
you know how he always does something
business well of course so some in the
business world you get some strange
thing again there is a because because I
always watched things not like this but
like this if I could
I always in my life what I did and this
is the common thing I did in my first in
my second life is watching things not in
under the traditional or the usual angle
or the usual point of view you know
because I always thought that if you see
things like this you can even see it
like see them like this because there's
always a different way to approach just
to give you an example in 2006 I made
the start up of plastic watches the name
of the company was tots right okay the
color was different color yeah that was
my sister and and when I was talking to
some of my friends colleague
entrepreneur they they used to say what
are you doing with with these plastic
watches you can find on the beach and
there were many people that were talking
about in the financial world I mean they
were talking about accessible luxury
which is something that it's impossible
were you always creative were you always
create even from you were yes because my
family is divided in 50 percent to
people that are related to heart and 50
percent people that were dealing with
interpret way with stuff regarding
companies or business or something
I had both blogs who were you know if I
was in school with you were in tenth
grade were in high school yeah who was
Gianluca baki in school first of all and
it's very weird to say I was a very shy
guy I was a super shy guy yes even in
high school yeah I was very shy because
I used to be a skier I was a
professional skier until eighteen years
old I used to live like in the mountains
and and and my life was poor was I was
like this and and so I was very shy when
I was meeting guys that were living in
town for example you know because I
would that was very shy and and in my
name my attitude my character had
changed a lot you know because they have
a girlfriend at a time will you we will
use somebody back
that was existing me my ski the mountain
of them in my performance and that's the
chronometer focus I've been so focused
in anything I've done you know I was so
professional
anytime so you went to University of
Bologna Bologna
I finished when I was like 20 almost 25
and I started immediately like trying to
restructure what were the interest of
the world
what was the worth of my family you know
because we had interest in in different
sectors and I tried to understand which
which could be the sectors that that
would have had most growth potential you
know and and focused on that yeah and I
focused on that and I started to buy the
shares of some of my cousins which I
were not interested in the family
company got together with the cousin
that today is my partner in the kin in
the company in the minim in the most
important company we own and he is a
shareholder as I am but is pres
president and CEO what is it called am i
or is ima ima ima and that company's
market cap is three billion or season
which is around three billion three
billion dollars yeah you three billion
euro okay three billion euro so after
college you're 25 you're done you start
doing business
when did you start because you said when
you were in high school your your skin
your very focus yeah yeah when you
graduate from college is that when you
kind of started having fun is that kind
of when you started how my study that
started very late to have fun this may
be the reason why I started very late
yeah maybe this is the reason why I'm
having a lot now so interesting when I
was 25 I had a big debt to buy all the
shares of my cousin which were not
interested in the family companies you
know and then I did ten years in which I
was not even going on holiday how many
years around ten years because I yes
from 25 to 35 I was really focused on
paying my debts and make the company
growing like you know the Joker you're
not married no kids you not married when
I was 27 and I did for three years
because I was soft
in my mind my strategy strategic plans
there was like okay I have to have a
wife because I gotta be so concentrated
so focused and so I was not reliable as
a husband because one thing is partying
one thing is being attracted by what so
you know yourself you know what you were
for ten years I was so concentrated and
I ni day and I did my first money then
immediately I started to do the house of
my life because there are people that
are much richer than I am much because
for me I mean in in terms of like being
rich I'm only interested in being rich
in the moments bank account
you know once they're gonna be the
motive the bank accounts of moments I
want to be in the fortune ranking until
for the rest I don't care so money for
me is not a would was a target when I
was 20 but as soon as I started to do it
I understood that I needed the money
there was enough for the quality of my
life and any of my friends do friends
live with you like you have like you
said your cousin's your best friend you
guys on yeah I have with your cousin do
you live with my cousin my cousin
unfortunately now I'm leaving some month
five at least here in Miami so I'm based
for a certain period here in our base in
Italy for another period but then from
there I tour a lot you seem like a very
attractive not physically person
physically of course but I'm talking
personality was your personality is so
attractive this is the best compliment
you can yeah you are you have such an
attractive personality this is the only
the only compliment occasional here's
from me I'm sharing it with you because
when you look at somebody and you you
see this person that knows who they are
and they're comfortable in their own
skin and they're living the truth you
can tell that person's having fun being
themselves
yeah you are so true with yourself
that's how you come across this is this
is the best compliment you can do to me
because this is exactly what I want
appear because I don't I never put a
filter and a mask between me and the
person else when I have in front of me
so now okay 35 you said 25 to 35 I make
my
yeah I work no holidays then you buy the
three houses because it's what you
wanted to do because if you don't have
quality life all this stuff so then at
what point did you say at 45 I'm going
to stop working that hard and I'm gonna
go enjoy my life when did you say at 45
I'm gonna go out and focus on having fun
of me you got a DJ set up right back
yeah your set up here's the guy that
lives with me with his wife is the DJ
that works with me
you know we do music together because we
put we are DJ producers you know and so
we do both things say why don't you say
I'm gonna have fun at 40 for me
everything is driven by curiosity you
know when I was 45 starting from the
point of view that I'm not interested
about accumulating money I don't want to
live into a routine then so I always
delegated in my business activity so I
had time I had free time but I didn't
want to talk about I was performing a
comp I mean I didn't want to talk about
it like every day I was performing a
company I was evolving a sector I this
manager wants to go so we have to find
another one no no I was not interested
anymore
and I always was like attracted by those
people who had to life
there was an entrepreneur in France it
was the owner of adidas and a certain
point he had some problems and he's
reached and he became an actor his name
was Bernard Tapie and I was always at
attracted by people that had the courage
to change their because it's very I mean
having a successful life is super
difficult okay yes it is having to
satisfaction life is even almost
impossible we're not happy but not happy
people not happy
and I said to myself if I can have two
lives I'm gonna be so happy because
because you need like to have like
electricity in your blood you know this
is what I so how can you have it if you
always have the same routine always have
the same routine imagine what what is
for me going in front of people
performing some music they are 20 years
old so this is something that give me a
lot
affection let's call and then what I
always say to my friends imagine how
interesting is passing from a meeting
room with lawyers and bankers to a
meeting with a producer with a singer
now it happens to me to deal with import
very important seniors you know this
year I'm gonna I'm gonna have so many
proposal to act for example and this is
I'm gonna do you're gonna act yes excite
about it yeah of course
I'm excited about every new things you
know because this is you get rich only
only through their because people think
sometimes and I did when I was younger
think that they are eternal you know
they have no no they're not affected by
the things that they when did you
realize that when did you realize your I
realized I realized my life change it
really around forty four forty five
years old that's something happier
because when I was thirty thirty five
thirty I was saying I'm young and I was
not thinking about the projection of my
life when I was 45 when I started to say
time is passing you know in that I
realized that being an entrepreneur the
most important loan we receive is life
you know that for sure we have to give
it back but just we don't know when so
that's the loan of the light was not
what we received from banks yeah so
that's that's yes let alone where you
have to give back for sure but the real
loan of your of your life is your life
you know I am a guest in my life not
owner of my life you know so and this is
the philosophy that I apply to
everything you know so this house yes is
his mind I what does what does it mean
in his mind how can I own something when
I when I don't own my life because my
life is about it's a barrel you know so
he's a mortgage is I don't know you know
so I started to say that and I said no i
wanna i wanna run now it's the moment if
I wanna run another second life it's now
the moment and I switched and I said
okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna I want to do
stuff there are totally different I have
to tell you because I'm very sincere
hello I've always been attracted by
idea of being very popular but because I
thought that I had something to share
with the others like vibes like you know
I mean I don't not pretending to be a
role model you know but that because I
lived the other people free to judge
what they want to think about me if they
want to see me as a role model they can
do but for sure I'm generous because I
expose myself and then if you and then
many many people took me like a role
model you know in the sense that for
example Mandurah
there are 50 years old and maybe they
are like you know not considering the
fact the fact that I getting fat or
they're losing their flexibility saying
hey why I should if he's like this I
could be like this or I mean why I have
to leave my body going you know and
saying oh I'm taking one kilo per year
one kilo every six months and and I mean
why so that that they're like seeing me
that's a oh I'm gonna exercise more I
want to keep myself more in shape young
people say okay it's possible to do
things because for example many people
meet me and say you don't need didn't
need to be J and I always say you don't
do things because you need you do things
because you have the passion to do
things the problem of this era and is
now I mean is Israeli a problem is that
people are more focused on what they
need to do so to survive and less to
what they have to dream about you know
which is something that people can tell
me is it's easy for you yes it's easy
now it's easy yes but it was not easy
before because I wasn't born like I was
like I am today you know what I mean I
mean worked at ten years no vacation 25
to 35 yes but I mean my father was was I
cannot say that he was rich because I
mean I don't define myself rich and I
and I have 100 times the things that my
father had so if I was not reached and
so I started I started by a privileged
point of view but I risked what I had so
many times you know so many times you
think you're lucky you work your butt
off to get a belong I worked a lot yeah
so then you can say that work is
something related to being on a desk but
work is even reading strategies reading
reading the evolutions strategy and
managing the risk you reasons what do
you read a lot or you always I did a lot
I did that time you were living a lot so
your music videos did you think your
dancing videos were gonna go the way
they were like I think about my videos I
think about which is the next music I
have to do what can drive a person my
opinion only the curiosity of doing new
stuff
I wasn't driven by accumulating money so
why why going on keep keep going on like
doing the entrepreneur if I was not
interested you know I was a wall I was
surrounded as all people that were
related to business by pessimism by
crisis generally let me ask you this so
if you wouldn't have worked from 25 to
35 the way you were yeah if you didn't
experience that do you think you'd be
where you are today
absolutely so the importance was you
going for that 10 year run so that was a
big part of your story yeah
that that was a big part of my story
because because that was related with
the commitment of achieving work that
was my dream at the first era so at that
time do you think sometimes people
wanted the other way around like they
want this they want the boat they want
the house they want a girl but they
don't want to put the ten years in a
focused hard work exactly in this issue
because for example when I talk to young
people and I spend a lot of time to show
young people because I never refused to
a guy what wherever I am whatever I'm
doing whenever it is to refuse to talk
with a young guy that asked advices osco
never even if I'm out with a beautiful
woman that I'm that I'm really you know
if he if he comes I talked to him five
on ten they they went out when I asked
them what do you want to do I want to do
jungle karate say I know it's not a job
he's not a job is the consequence of a
job eventually you know Wow
so tell us about a new song trumpet Tam
because it's Trump or the Trump because
of Donald Trump you can play on it you
can play on it you can play on it you
can play on it
my first song the intro started from a
popular chant Colombian chant which I
that I found on YouTube and that chant
was the symbol of immigration of slaves
from Africa to Colombia
nobody's nothing related to politics I
mean I'm not interested about I'm super
interested when you can play with the
world that for sure you know that I'm
because you created yeah it's in trumpet
is like wow it's super super awesome but
I'm not thinking about the ha I don't
think that Donald Trump is gonna listen
the song because it has the name every
words so so dancing are you always
dancing everyday life even when I was
like full of them
like here yeah I had a grandmother which
was Argentinian and maybe I ever some
percentage of Latin American blood
because I'm always dancing I'm always
like you know how are you good teacher
of dancing you teach other people to
dance yes I'm not very patient
I mean I'm calm when when they don't
react well but I mean yes I did many
times can you take a minute and show me
a couple moves can you teach me a dance
move of course I can do that and see how
that's gonna be we'll take a break this
if we can pull this off I'm putting my
one other two is gonna happen if you if
we laugh we can do that's the point but
here Gianluca I got to tell you so
honestly first of all come into your
place beautiful place you have here
but my expectation of what I expected of
you and what I thought of you two after
meeting with you I mean you hear the
stories Michelle Rodriguez you know you
know that story 2011 Zac Efron I mean
you know yeah you're the net worth 300
million you hear the Instagram followers
yeah the videos you do hear all this
stuff you were in the video that's got
1.7 billion views it's Belvin it's a
junior Belvin right they said that song
is just a special song you come in right
up front you're a different person than
what I thought you were this is good
that's so interesting because it's good
even if it's very it's under a certain
point of view is frustrating because I
would love to share to all people not
only the superficial part of me which is
of course what it arrives to people
because social media is I mean give the
chance to people to see you but you know
like not going in that I always say to
people that to have to be successful in
what at the moment I'm successful in you
gotta be sensible for sure you got you
gotta you gotta be like intelligent or
something like that because if you have
success means that you understood what
people want in terms of like having fun
or being entertained or you know that
what if what I think is that the
contemporary society leaves without the
dream you know
because they all concentrated about oh I
need to do this I need to do this I need
to do this which is normal because we
have to deal with what we need but if I
wouldn't have dreamed in my life I would
never be what I am today
so what I'm doing is pushing people to
dream license motivation life is
motivational I think that people are not
believing in themselves anymore but
because the need is over passing the
desire definitely want to do this again
when we come back here we're always in
this town this is a beautiful town so
and if you would love to do that again
we would love whenever you once again
whenever you brother thank you so much
for your time truly thank you so much